well thanks for sticking around for this
last talk before coffee break and to the
organizer for giving me an opportunity
to show you some work on influenza
seasonality and climate factors so this
is work done in collaboration with many
people but I would like to point out in
particular Jeff shaman was going to give
a talk later in the morning but also
Jeanne pizza and Dan Weinberger were
here in the audience so I will talk
about two studies looking at influenza
seasonality and climatic factor one on a
global scale and moja tell study focused
on China and then I will talk about two
different disease systems two different
viruses respiratory syncytial virus and
rotavirus so for influenza it's been a
long lon that undescribed that does
marked wintertime seasonality in
temperate areas of the world and that
seasonality is less well defined in
tropical regions but the drivers of
seasonality of always remain and clear
there's been recent interest in the role
of specific humidity and I will get back
to that in a second and also there's
been a number of epidemiological studies
trying to lean climatic factors such as
temperature specific humidity
precipitation and influenza but in
specific location and not really a
global view of what the relationship
could be between the climate in
influenza so here what we're really
trying to to have a global explanation
of why influence I seasonal in some
places and not so season only novice so
in this graph with just this is just an
example of how diverse the seasonality
of influenza is around the world the
world so in enough northern us and
pretty much all of the US were very
seasonal epidemic with most of the viral
activity concentrated in winter months
in Reverse in the southern hemisphere
temperate regions such as Australia we
have also very strong seasonal pattern
in in the winter season and then in some
tropical places such as vitalia laser we
have also very much seasonality while in
our equatorial procedures at Singapore
we have your own circulation with some
epidemic pics in
stink tears and the problem with linking
influenza and climatic factors that not
that we don't have good ipod Aziz we
have too many of those ipod disease and
here this is a cartoon from a review
that we did a year or two ago trying to
assess some of the evidence for the
links between climate and influenza and
so climate could act upon different
steps of the transmission process in
particular in terms of contact right
very survival and immunity and for each
of those processes there's been evidence
that there's a link with climate for
instance it's been our seasonal factor
when something's been suggested that
contact rights will vary according to
school schedule but also to temperature
and precipitation and I'll also travel
and workflow which varies between the
year within the year could also affect
compact rate terms of our survival has
been also some data on the role of
humidity of relative and specific and
temperature on survival but also salade
radiation in terms of the immunity does
in the human host as even many more more
I potus is in particular involving
humidity for the period selenium and
temperature but also a bunch of vitamins
in particular the people in Britain are
really intrigued by the idea that
vitamin D could could drive a
seasonality of influenza and also the
idea that perhaps viral interference
with with other pathogens my drive some
of those seasonal cycles that we see so
really many many hypotheses and and is
there just one or maybe a combination of
hypotheses that is able to explain the
patterns that we see globally so just a
word on some interesting experimental
data both in animals and in humans that
have suggested that there's a link
between environmental factors and
influenza as transmission so here this
is from a few years ago experiments in
guinea pig in a pitiful ases group
showing that a transmission of influenza
between those guinea pigs fly or soul
varies with relative humidity and
temperature and in general lower level
of temperature and humidity favor
transmission there's also been some
interesting older experiments in humans
from live vaccination trials done in
Russia in the 1980s so it's basically an
infection with an attenuated virus but a
real infection and you see that the the
response of the human vaccine is depends
on the season and is actually hard as a
higher response in winter with increased
body temperature increase probability of
flowers isolation and increased
serological response as compared with
those that are vaccinated in summer so
decisions that they might also be a role
of season onion immunity and so just a
few words on a really interesting world
that Jeff did a few years ago trying to
reinterpret the animal the guinea pig
experiment that I've just told you about
in terms not only on terms of relative
humidity and temperature but combining
this into this measure of specific
humidity and showing that this is a much
more parsimonious way to explain the
relationship between transmission
influenza transmission and environmental
factor with love early levels of
specific humidity favoring transmission
and that's also true in terms of our
survival and this was follow followed by
the nice study looking at
epidemiological data in the US and
violation in specific humidity for the
year and you see a drop in specific
humidity a few weeks before the onset of
of the influenza season so that's also a
good explanation I mean a good
explanation for for the seasonal pattern
that we see in the US but the question
is does that work also for other regions
of the world in particular tropical and
equatorial regions so we've compiled try
to compile as much energy call
information on influenza seasonal
pattern as we could for locations around
the world and this is a study that's
just about to come out in interest
but here we are managed to find
information both from the literature and
from an electronic surveillance website
478 location with a good coverage of the
of the Tropic but one-third of a sample
is in the Tropic and of course a large
and oral presentation of Africa which is
jello quite understand terms of
influenza surveillance but based on this
literature review we can assess the
timing of peak influenza activity and
try to relate this with with climatic
factors so this is a plot showing the
distribution of the timing of influenza
activity across the 78 locations that we
have in the data set so from november to
for a full year as a function of
latitude and you recognize a very marked
winter seasonality in the high-latitude
northern hemisphere as well as in the
high-latitude server name is fair and in
the intermediate region does much more
viability in terms of when the timing of
influenza locales so we've tried to link
those data with a range of indicators
environmental indicators including
precipitation specific and relative
humidity and temperature and here will
you can get where we see for specific
humidity and so for each site we've
looked at the pic timing of influenza
and what was the level of specific
humidity in that month of peak influenza
and this is plotting here in the in the
dark solid line the proportion of sites
that have influenced a peek at different
levels of specific humidity so there's a
higher density of location having peak
influence at low level of humidity that
also high levels of humidity and the
gray shaded line in the background
represent the expected distribution that
we would have under the null hypothesis
where there's no relationship between
the two and so if we write this down by
tampered site we see that most most of
the tempered side have to peek in the
low specific humidity season which
agrees with Jeff's hypothesis from from
his earlier work and I in contrast in
tropical site most of the amount of
influence at peak in the high specific
humidity season season we can also plug
the data as a function of
minimum specific humidity that each
location experience throughout the year
so here the locations are started by
those levels of minimum specific
humidity the round gray bar represent
the ranch of viability of specific
humidity in the different locations so
you see that in some location does very
little liability and in others as a
large liability in specific humidity and
black dot represent the humidity level
in the month where influenza peaks and
you see that for all of those location
on the left-hand side of the curve which
tend to have many low minimum levels of
humidity sometime during the year well
this is when they will have their peak
influenza seasons well another location
which have always have high levels of
specific humidity here one while
influence our occurs in the month of
highest level of specific humidity while
intermediate zone that spans a threshold
here of specific humidity around 10 to
12 grand per kilogram you can have
influence I pick pretty much even the
hiram EDT modifying the low humidity
mountain that's also where you'll find
locations with to influenza peaks during
the year so then we can work out a
relationship between the probability of
an influence that because as a function
of specific humidity and you see this
trough of probability of occurrence of
influence are around 10 to 12 gram per
kilogram so if we did the same analysis
we talk with temperature we would also
find a pretty similar threshold for
temperature with a location that go
below 18 to 20 degrees Celsius I think
also a high probability of an influence
epic during the winter months so a
specific humidity is perhaps mostly a
marker for for when and influence that
peak may may occur but it could be that
the relationship between climate and
flow occurs through other environmental
factors so next we try to use the
climate based predictions to predict the
timing of influenza in our data set and
so this is a result from different
models both univariate and multivariate
and we see that the model that has both
temperature and specific humidity has
the best predictive power which is not
excellent but it's it's seventy percent
so it's not bad and and in particular
deity
accuracy in temperate region is very
good in low latitude region is
reasonable and really where we have
trouble predicting something is in those
mid latitude regions that that crosses
this threshold of 10 10 to 12 a gram per
kilogram of specific humidity some of
the other models do Earl as well but if
you look at the model that has Pacific
that have precipitation or relative
humidity they tend to be quite accurate
in terms of predicting few in low
latitude regions just because they
predict that fear will occur during the
rainy season which we what where we see
in the data so next we can use this
model to predict the seasonal behavior
of influenza in different regions of the
world where we don't necessarily have
influenced the data and this map
progress on the probability having a
cold and dry pick so pick in the winter
pretty much in purple versus the
probability of having a peak in the
humid rainy season in green and you see
that in the middle attitude region
that's where we see the occurrence of
oven after Ramadan and rainy peaks and
this is the model here based on specific
humidity minimum level of specifically
DT we will have a very similar
prediction if we use the model based on
minimum temperature except that those
model disagree quite a bit in and what
they predict for Africa with a central
Africa here having a large probability
of a larger real probability of rainy
you need pics while the model based on
specific humidity has a much restricted
array of those you need rainy pics so if
we had more data from Africa would be a
good way to distinguish between the
world of temperature and specific
humidity perhaps and that it does hope
here because there's actually a lot body
that coming coming from Africa in in
recent years so in the in the analysis
that I've just shown you we've used very
crude data were very good measure
measures of influenza seasonality which
basically just a pic timing but we were
able to do it for many different
locations here we've we've tried to see
whether the same model
shown you before based on temperature
and specific humidity was also good at
predicting the whole seasonal
distribution of influenza cases during
the year and so here we see on some
seasonal distribution of influenza in
brown for based on data from the wh 0
surveillance website through net and so
if you see that some sites we have very
strongly seasonal distribution and in
other side we have more year-round
circulation of the viruses and then the
blue and red line here represent the
predictions of the model so we are quite
able to predict your own circulation in
Vietnam and and sit more seasonal
distribution in countries like Senegal
and in Tunisia and our prediction on are
less accurate in other places and you
see here the different season in
climatic factors in some of those
regions and using a summer some of this
more refined method to characterize
seasonality that's relying on time
series we can also measure something
like the seasonal amplitude which is a
measure of the difference between the
minimum and the max of the number of
cases in a year and we can see strong
relationship with latitude so here it's
again using data from through net a much
louder data set because we cover 85
countries but it's a much more
aggregated spatial scale so not
necessarily good to a look at
relationship with Claire mad but good to
have a broader view of what the seasonal
patterns are so we see here in an oven
hemisphere a strong relationship between
latitude and seasonal amplitude where
places that have that high latitude have
a higher seasonal amplitude of influenza
cases this is for the northern
hemisphere this is for the southern
hemisphere color-coded by region but you
see the same pretty much as in
relationship in both hemispheres we can
also look at pic timing and we also see
a nicer gradient where countries that
are at higher latitude tend to have
later epidemics in the season and that's
true again both of the northern and the
southern hemisphere separately the other
nice interesting thing here is that
those horizontal vows not viability
in Pig timing between years and we can
show that there's more viability in
those low latitude regions than there is
in the high-latitude region when the
peak of influenza locales and finally
differences in epidemic duration as well
where we see that the place is at lower
latitudes tend to have longer influence
our seasons that place is at high energy
and so a few more world about some
recent work that with that we've started
with collaborators at the Chinese CDC
look it you can get a more refined time
series data from different provinces in
China where they have a good
surveillance for from net 2005 to now
for the 30 different provinces of China
and shine obviously there is a great
country to look at because its
population is so large but also climatic
drivers are so different as well as
social economy drivers across provinces
so here the color code of this graph
representing different climatic zones of
China so blue and sorry red and brown
represent not temperate regions blue is
a subtropical and does here one province
in the really tropical area in southern
China and so we can look at the
seasonality of influenza in those
different regions which are here sajid
from north down to self and so you see
very strongly seasonal cycle of
influenza cases so the red represent
high intensity of flu yellow and light
yellow is low intensity so he sido
strong seasonal vertical wells here
representing seasonal cycle centered
around winter month in about half of the
provinces and then below 33 degrees of
latitude you see much more diverse Azure
no cycles and less clear seasonality so
this is the same data but summarized
here into an annual seasonal
distribution of seasonal signature of
influenza and again you recognize the
strong seasonal winter focus of epidemic
in the north of China and ma diversity
in the south but with the I mean the
idea that perhaps in dos mil a teacher
vences we have to influence that peak
during the year one in the winter and
another one in the soul so I wanted to
quantify those patterns a little more so
we fit a time series model to this data
to estimate the annual amplitude the
timing of the epidemic and the strength
of the semi-annual to a duel component
so whether there is a semi annual cycle
or not and so we see that the annual
amplitude is stronger in the north of
China as competitiveness with the south
of China but epidemics tend to occur
later in the north of China as compared
with the self which tends to have summer
epidemics and also that the mid-latitude
provinces of China tend to have a
stronger semiannual components to
epidemics icons within the year we can
also try to define epidemiological
imagine us region and this is very
useful for Chinese collaborators at the
CDC because they're about to embark on
the national vaccination campaign but to
do this every year you have to know
something about the time of timing of
influenza activity and so the idea would
be to break down china into birdie a big
energy cause a similar region to be able
to to vaccinate people right before in
time for the influenza season in those
regions and so by doing a cluster
analysis of the time series data we see
that we see three different regions the
region here on the right which is the
temperate region were epidemics occur in
in the winter the region on the left
here which is the southernmost region of
China which has summer academics and
here the middle latitude regions which
have to epidemics within the year so if
you wanted to vaccinate you with
vaccinate here before the winter in the
North before the summer season in the
south and in the middle latitude well
that's the question would you vaccinate
twice in the year or just once in the
year but during the I mean that but that
remains to be seen but that is there are
three different regions that need to be
considered and then we can look at
traumatic factor as well as over
Geographic and and travel movement
patterns that best discriminate between
those three different regions
and with you an effect of temperature
humidity as well as a solar radiation I
think that's what's here in
discriminating between this pattern this
is more of a finger preliminary and
expiratory analysis here just because we
have only 30 different provinces and
that's really not enough to to run an
analysis but not based on a lot of
different potential factors but
presumably if we had a similar time
series data from a lot of locations
around the world we could those types of
enemies and the last bit of information
about China which is quite interesting
is that we were able to break down the
analysis by different types of influenza
so there are two types of flu flu way
and 4b and weave in fluid as also
different subtypes but we see that for
flu be whichever we have a much more
pronounced winter seasonal pattern that
we have for freeway so blue represent a
timing of activity concentrated around
the winter mountain and red is in the
summer month so basically a few beans
winter seasonal fruit most of China
accepting in South almost hainan
province well if you have a few areas as
more diverse pattern of activity and
that's intriguing because the animal
experiments unfortunately were only done
with fewer viruses so we don't know
whether few b viruses responds
differently to environmental condition
than fluid oz the guinea pig in a pig
model box for flu be so i think they're
going to maybe do those climate
experiments at some point but it would
be really interesting to see whether
those introducing differences in the
virus or whether it's a difference in
the host with Ruby for instance X
infecting more children which might have
different compact patterns than adults
um so in summary I think we're just at
the beginning of working out the
relationship between influenza
seasonality and climate a lot of
possible climatic factors that could be
associated but we see we see strong
geographical variation and particular
attitudinal gradients in seasonality in
seasonally
seasonal amplitude and timing of
epidemic across the world based on our
global study we see a bimodal
relationship between specific humidity
where of low levels of specific humidity
and high levels of specific ability
favor transmission so the low level part
of the relationship can be well
explained by the experiment the animal
and the animal experimented I've shown
that virus survival and virus
transmission increase it at low levels
of humidity the relationship were high
levels of humidity favors in for the
transmission is more difficult to
explain we don't have any good
mechanistic explanation but it could be
perhaps for the hypothesis that behavior
changes during the rainy season people
congregate more and so that's higher
crowding it's it's difficult to test but
maybe we will be able to do that with
the thresholds of specific humidity of
temperature that define whether
influence i will occur during the cold
months or during the rainy season month
and other seasonality in the middle
latitude is really difficult to predict
and here we think that perhaps there's
some impact of other factors non
climatic factors such as population
travel and that's an interesting real to
study we also see interesting
seasonality differences between few and
through B which remains to be clarified
and I think of all this this also begs a
question that we always get okay so flu
is less seasonal in the truck it does
that mean there is more or less disease
in the tropics and unfortunately when
we're not able to answer this very basic
question about how much sugar is in
different areas of the world so that's
also an interesting area for future
study okay so in the last few minutes
just a few words on an ongoing work on
the seasonality of rotavirus and
respiratory syncytial virus so those are
two different disease viral disease
system so rotavirus is an enteric virus
and RSV is a respiratory virus
transmitted through pretty much the same
route as fruit only for combination of
direct and indirect transmission oh well
what did I do good and so in the same in
the same way that we compiled a global
image of the timing of activity around
the world we were able to do the same
thing for hours we even where there's a
lesser publicly available data that a
sketch a bit of literature in RSV and so
we see the same broad pattern that we
see for flu in that there's more winter
seasonality in the northern hemisphere
high latitude and server name is your
high latitude but there's also some
suggestion that there's a little bit
more variability than then for flu and
here already for the u.s. you see that
those differences in timing of RSV that
we don't necessarily see for fluid the
same scale but it would be a relatively
interesting to do the same type of
analysis that we did for flu with desire
sv data so we also have more resolved
RSV data for for the US and this is what
I'm showing here so this is a map of the
timing of activity in that in countries
work for which we have enough
hospitalization data and you see a
strong variation in timing and since
very consistent between years with
epidemic starting in October in in
southern Florida and studying much later
in the north-western northeast of the US
with about a Fremont flag between the
earliest country under later County and
so if you call a this against a
different geographical factors such as
latitude but also temperature or
humidity you see a strong relationship
and so we're still trying to to work out
the details of which climatic factors is
associated with RSV and also trying to
reconcile the fact that this is pretty
much a winter bug that but even though
it's a winterberg it has earlier timing
of onset in Florida which is a very warm
place so we're still trying to work out
the mechanist the mechanism here that
explain why why RSV is so specially
structured and to finish just a few
words on on a rotavirus richer which is
this a antivirus for which we now have a
vaccine engineers done a lot of work on
this disease system if if
jung mal chance to really talk to her
but this is also from a recent review of
rotavirus seasonality that coming out in
a pediatric infectious-disease journal
with our CDC colleagues and that also
shows a lot of viability in in a
rotavirus timing of activity in
different areas of the world we perhaps
even more variability that what we see
for RSV or influenza and so in this this
review we also try to correlate seasonal
seasonal patterns of rotavirus against a
range of demographic as well as
environmental and socio-economic factors
and we found actually that a temperature
of rainfall explained little in the
seasonal amplitude of rotavirus but
income actually explain more of the
viability of all the model here
explained thirteen percent of the
variance which means that we still don't
understand a lot about what a virus
seasonality but this doesn't seem to be
a clear link with traumatic viable and
then genial has also done some really
nice work linking differences in birth
rates and transmission rates in
different places of the world with
different season seasonal patterns so it
looks like for rotavirus does not
perhaps not such a clear link with
climate so so in summary does a lot of
similarities between those 3d effects
disease system few hours you and what a
virus in that these are actually winter
seasonal viruses in temperate and
temperate regions of the world they all
both all the fur of them are directly
transmitted and imperfectly immunizing
so you get reinfected throughout life
and for all three of them you could
probably say that there's mark winter
seasonality and temperate area and less
problem seasonality in the tropics but
actually the drivers of seasonality
differ quite a bit and so I think we
really need a global studies like those
types of study to try to match
epidemiological data against lomatic
factors as well as demographic and
geographic factors to try to understand
the drivers of
Manatee and also thinking about the
effect of birth rates transmission rate
socioeconomic factors population mixing
and also different season in circulating
strains so thank you very much to my
collaborators the few work was done in
the context of the multinational
influence I study that we have at NIH at
the forget international center and that
involves many collaborators around the
world thank you